Speaker 1: All right. It is time for Friday
Feedback. We're calling it Friday feedback
now instead of the mailbag, because we are
just regularly incorporating elements that
aren't actually emails. And as you know, I want
both precision and clarity and it is not really
accurate to call it the email bag when we are
highlighting elements from Facebook or Reddit
or YouTube or whatever the case may be. So same
stuff. New name, Friday feedback. All right, let's
get right into it, starting with some critiques
to put it lightly. Wanda wrote in and Wanda says,
You and your page must be a comedian slash comedy,
because to think Biden is brave and has done
anything good for this country is sad and blinded.
Well, Wanda, you win an award. You are a critic
who used the correct form of your versus your
correctly using while you are to show possession.
It is my page. I used to say it is almost a
requirement that you use the wrong your when
you write in with hate mail, but one to use the
correct one. Now in terms of Biden is brave and
has done anything good, there is a long list of
good things that Joe Biden has done. We've talked
about it and it is a very wide ranging inflation
reduction act, COVID stimulus, the attempt to do
some student loan debt relief, although it's now
tied up in court, getting out of Afghanistan. I
think going to Ukraine was a super interesting
and politically savvy thing to do, laying the
trap around Social Security and Medicare, which
completely upended the way Republicans were
talking about. I mean, there's a very long list of
things that Joe Biden has done is in my favorite
president is even the best president is. Was he my
number one pick? No, but we're trying to be adults
here. Want to please. And such black and white
thinking is very, very sad. Susan Rodin also on
Facebook. This is so damn funny. I'm going to tell
you what's going on here. Okay. Susan wrote to me,
Stay off my f ing page lib tard following
it up with Trump 47 Go Brandon. And then
put by dumb in a nursing home jail with Hillary
Clinton and the Obama boys. Oh, bomb now. Yeah,
this is a thing that happens a lot. There are non
tech savvy right wingers who don't understand how
algorithms work. And as many of you know, if you
regularly watch videos on Facebook, you might be
scrolling. This is me scrolling on my phone, you
might be scrolling, and then you're looking at
Facebook video and it's just showing you things.
It's showing you things algorithmically. It's
showing you things randomly. It's just showing you
stuff. And if you don't like something and you're
sort of like a normal person, you just scroll past
it. There are people on the right who will contact
us on Facebook who seem to think that we need
to remove our content from their quote page. And
that's where you end up with stuff like this. Stay
off my f ing page lib tard. Now Susan could just
press I don't like this. And then she would never
see our content again. But a lot of tech confusion
as to, you know, Yeah, I'm sitting here saying
show Susan my clips Facebook please. Dear God.
Michael wrote in about media coverage of the grand
jury foreperson in Georgia in that Trump related
grand jury. And Michael said, David love the show,
keep up the great work. Why isn't anyone talking
about media coverage of Emily? Cause CNN literally
aired an interview of Miss Coors, Dave, divulging
inappropriate grand jury information, then
proceeded to lambaste her actions as irresponsible
on Anderson Cooper. I would expect a reputable
news outlet to know better than to broadcast
such inappropriate and sensitive information. Does
the media bear responsibility? I don't think so,
no. I think, you know, if media outlets say
we're not going to name mass shooters because
there's a specific reason to avoid glorifying
and giving them the fame that they seek,
I think that's totally fine and legit to say we
aren't going to show newsworthy stuff that someone
else has chosen to provide because of how it
might impact a case, even though there is no legal
issue, I just see it as very different. I don't
think CNN is doing anything wrong. It should be up
to the jury foreperson to decide is it appropriate
for me to speak or not and for whatever
court related of. Authorities to manage that. But
I don't think media outlets are doing anything
wrong by showing the interviews. Derek also wrote
in about Emily cause and says, sounds like someone
close to Trump got to this woman more tampering.
Nobody in their right mind would think this is a
good idea except Trump. A few people did write
in and say, You know, David, it occurred to me
that maybe this was something someone on the
Trump side encouraged Emily cause to do this
bizarre media tour, knowing it would be useful to
Trump. It's I understand why people are making the
suggestion. I have no evidence that that's what
happened, but it would be interesting to look into
it. Dean wrote to me about Donald Trump's plant.
I think it means plan to eliminate crime and says,
Hey, David, someone should ask Trump if he
could eliminate crime in the U.S. Why didn't he
eliminate crime in the U.S. during his four years
in office? You know, it's a perfectly reasonable
and sensible question, but if you presented it
to Trump, Trump would say that it was because of
Democrats. Democrats blocked him from doing it.
But if you vote him in next time, he'll have the
House and Senate. And this time Democrats won't
be able to block him. Or, you know, we often feel
in politics that we have these gotchas. And of
course, Dean's question is 100% reasonable. Like
if why are you now saying you're going to do
all these great things which you couldn't or
didn't do during your first term? They have an
answer. They have an. And the point is their
followers will accept that answer. Kevin wrote
to me and said, David, do you have any advice
in regards to particular methods you find useful
to keep yourself strong in the face of constant,
terrible news with Flint, Michigan, now Ohio?
It's become very apparent to me. We're on our own.
Our leaders don't care about us at all. I find it
disgusting that Democrats are unwilling to speak
up at all about Ohio. I don't know if that's true.
And they let Trump swoop in and act like he gives
an s about anybody other than himself. It was a
good move Trump pulled. Going there makes him look
good. It's hard to remain hopeful when it seems
like fascism is about to fully take hold and has
no real opposition whatsoever. Keep it up, David.
Hopefully the internet remains intact and you can
continue to upload. It's important to know what's
going on. Honestly, I know that a lot of people
aren't going to like this, but honestly, here is
what I recommend to keep yourself sane. Understand
there is a limit to the number of issues you as
an individual can fix. And for health reasons,
it's really important to say this is going to be
my intake of this stuff and that's going to be it.
You I've said for me, unless I'm like streaming
something on the weekend from the time I'm done
with the Friday show until I start working on
the Monday show, I pay no attention to news and
politics and it is really healthy to set those
limits because you're right, Kevin. Otherwise it
becomes overwhelming in that way. Ellen wrote in
and says, David, you set out all the reasons why
it wouldn't make sense for Trump to sign the
Republican loyalty pledge. But we all know he
doesn't think rules apply to him ever. My guess is
it wouldn't bother him to, at least in the least,
to sign the loyalty pledge when it benefited him
by getting him on stage and then turn right around
and run as a third party candidate. If it suits
him, he'll have no trouble at all. True thing that
it was a plot by the rhinos and he's not bound
by it. Ellen's completely correct. And in fact,
I mentioned this on the Monday show. Trump's
most likely scenario is if he has to sign the
pledge to debate, he'll do it. And then if he
loses and wants to run a third party, he'll do
it. And when people say, well, but what about
that loyalty pledge, sir? He'll say it doesn't
apply because they rigged it and they stole it.
And whatever Thorstein wrote in about me taking
time off and says, Dear David, sir, I'm a great
fan of your show. And just for the mailbag video,
that's the reason I want to say something positive
about your supporting your replacements. None of
them are as good as you are. That's because it's
your show. But all of them did a very good job.
It's extremely hard to replace the frontrunner
of a show even for a short time of vacation or
parental leave. Everybody has his own voice
style way of speaking of declaring something,
I think you did a good job with the picks. Well, I
appreciate that. And then lastly, from TB or TBM.
Hello, David. I wish to thank you for not
starting your broadcasts with the words. So
I've begun to avoid sites that do you. So to start
a broadcast is a sloppy is. What's up, everyone?
Both of these rank up there with at this point in
time or in this moment, both of which drive me to
distraction. Laziness has no place in journalism.
I'm pleased the malaise hasn't infected your
programs. Yeah. So I guess that would be like if
I started a show with something like So Donald
Trump did another crazy thing. I guess. I don't
do that. I've never I've never noticed people in
general doing that. But to the extent that TB
likes that I don't start my episodes with so.
I am at your service tbe tbe thank
you very much for for letting me know.
Remember, you may be featured in Friday
feedback. If you respond to me on Twitter,
leave a YouTube comment. Respond on Facebook,
whatever the case may be. And you also of
course can continue to email info at David
Pakman dot com. If you have something to say,
we also now have the David Pakman show in
Spanish with where are we? From the standpoint of
subscribers, where are we doing on Spanish? Right
around the 2000 mark. Yep. So we are building the
Spanish channel. It is the same content dubbed
into Spanish for folks who prefer to consume the
content in Spanish. You can go to David Pakman
dot com slash Spanish to find the channel and
I will see you next week. And producer Pat's on
the bonus show today. We'll see you in a moment.